[Music]
all right you everything you do you're a
very smart man everything you do is
calculate it you set the internet on
fire with those pictures what was they I
know what was this
tell me the story behind that game white
famous come see me and Kevin Frazier
playing
that's Jamie Foxx playing coy about his
rumored romance with actress Katie
Holmes all at the premiere of his new
Showtime comedy series white famous but
when it comes to the show which
premieres on October 15th he couldn't
help but gush undercurrent for African
American comedians how do you how do you
do your act coming from the comedy never
went to Sunset Boulevard until it was
actually time to audition for and live
in color like I did all of my jokes in
the hood Crenshaw and then you know that
step of being okay now mainstream white
bangs so we took that incredible idea of
showing Jay using some of the stories
that I've gone through to where it's
just guy trying to hold on to us you
know to his where he started right so
what you wanna talk about you know I
just want to talk about it soldier it is
true your first scene in the in this
show really is off the chain yeah
because what it is is like like what I
told you where did that come from no I
told Jay Esther Jay me you never want to
meet your heroes so if Jamie Foxx
and you come in this trailer you should
be like what is going along with this
dude and basically there's always been
the thing of like should you wear a
dress like you know meet me wearing a
dress roughly 1/2 Martin all of the
great comments that have done it but on
the under like some kind of yell man you
had the right dress you had to sell out
so me and in the pilot episode of me
trying to see people compromise and wear
the wear the dress and every comedian
out there really first off they're gonna
understand what that is and then
[Music]
you